hey I'm Kira hey I'm butch creator of
fairly oddparents Danny fan on the tuff
puppy and Bunsen is a beast on
Nickelodeon and today we're drawing
Studio Ghibli characters from memory and
be sure to stick around at the end of
the video to find out how you can enter
for a chance to win this Wacom Intuos
tablet courtesy of our good friends at
welcome creative there's two free
creative software downloads and
pistachios it doesn't come with
pistachios it's the colors pistachio I
think everyone's gonna get mad at me
I've always seen a limited number of
Miyazaki films
I appreciate what he's done but I'm
tremendously but the drawing things from
memories gonna be a little tricky for me
I love some more recent anime like one
punch man and stuff like that I also
love older anime like Speed Racer oh you
know I really don't wanna get though
that witch from spirited away it was
like a thousand wrinkles on her face
yeah I want to get her I see only one
who's not like an innocent woman yeah oh
my god I love Kiki's Delivery Service I
haven't seen this film since it came out
in the u.s. so like 90s yeah so Kevin's
oh you start drawing Kevin oh wait no
[Music]
he's like a bunch of triangles use
triangles
[Music]
she's the old lady she's the old lady
yeah she's like a big giant old lady a
huge head like kind of a like a bob like
a samurai yeah I remember seeing this
movie as well as movies where you hear
that it's like a classic and it's
amazing yeah and you watch it and it's
like oh my god like it's a classic it's
amazing you know yeah Jackie I'm nervous
for this because as you know I do not
draw in an anime style you really don't
the question is do I actually attempt to
draw in an anime style or do I do my own
thing I feel like if you try to do it
there's one thing the comments have told
me Jackie is that when I draw in my own
way it ends up looking like me from what
I remember of her she's kind of like she
looks like an ogre almost she's like a
troll so mean super wrinkly super
detailed every time I watched it I was
kind of like amazed that they had to
redraw her I said that man that many
times it's so hard I have never seen
this character I'd be very honest with
you I'm just kind of making up an old
lady what's like the animal he's closest
to is it like a teddy bear like not even
a raccoon
he's got whiskers yeah oh thanks for
telling me that I didn't know
does he have teeth at all yes yeah yeah
like when he opens his mouth to do that
he's got like a full set of like human
teeth I don't know if you can see Kiki
in your mind but her outfit is very
simple it's just she's just wearing a
dress yeah and she has like props that
you know right she has a broom yeah and
oh she has like a big bone yeah yes yes
okay yep that's for all the people who
say I never help Kevin I help Kevin all
the time I help him cross the street I
help them get some sugar from his
neighbors I don't know what else old
people do you do help me check what is
you Baba wearing what does she wear like
a kimono thing she's wearing like um
it's kind of like one of those long old
lady dresses where it's like long
sleeves it's blue I have a ton of those
at my house you know
got what's your favorite Studio Ghibli
film I honestly really love spirited
away really yeah
but also uh mmm I really like Howl's
Moving Castle - my favorite Ghibli movie
is Princess Mononoke yes
nossek on the valley of the wind which I
think was very underrated yeah so what's
your favorite Studio Ghibli felt am I
saying it right is it Ghibli or Ghibli
um no I say Studio Ghibli I say Ghibli I
think you're valid okay but my favorite
Ghibli movies probably spirited away
angry I love that old near and dear to
my heart close second though Porco Rosso
really does she have a stick or a weapon
of any kind or a UH I don't think so
she has a lot of rings on her fingers
though she does yeah okay
she holds like an umbrella am i right oh
yeah that's a super iconic scene but one
where they were waiting for the cat bus
oh they're waiting okay I don't have
them waiting for anything it's like a
big tail see I don't know I think
there's like a tail but like every tail
I give them doesn't look right I gave
them like a like a bunny tail here's
what I love about
Studio Ghibli movies not everything is
explained mm-hmm like sometimes just
like weird things happen and they never
explain it and I'm like you know what I
like that yeah who needs the explanation
yeah I feel really cleaning everything
is a very Western form of storytelling
that's very true Kevin I think about
this a lot when it comes to storytelling
are you patronizing me right no I'm not
I'm this is being for reals because I
think a lot of people's criticisms
against anime movies is that there's no
ending right but it doesn't have to have
it right because life doesn't have an
ending unless you die yeah I love the
feel of this tablet though this is
really cool yeah they're really nice I
don't know what they did to like the
glass on top but it feels a lot more
premium than like other tablets I've
drawn on its got like a texture to it it
feels like you're kind of drawing
more like natural surface like paper
remember the first time I discovered I
could make a gradient on the background
my life changed that day he's great
right
no he's around right Turner oh there's
nothing he's got to be seen like
brownish gray oh my god what's happening
I was like confident and now I don't
know I wouldn't do that I'm gonna hope
that she has blue eyes okay I think it
got his color he needs like a brown gray
yeah I'm almost done just get me away
three seconds or it's like 30 more
seconds 302 ah
did you just dab yeah who dabs anymore I
did
I'm as done as I'll ever be I think if I
did not put those arrows on his chest
you wouldn't know it really you know
that was it yeah all Totoro is some
arrows his arrows on his chest and the
umbrella okay that's that's about all I
can do I think again like I always say I
think I got the gist of them down but I
definitely miss them are like how do you
think you did I think I did okay you
know I think it's cute I think for a
quick sketch it's pretty good I thought
I did terribly oh and I want to
apologize for all of you Ghibli fans out
there I don't know if you guys can see
it but Kevin is tearing up right now
he's really about to cry Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god oh my god okay you were right
he's great
very good very good teeth you're talking
about teeth your teeth in here are very
good yeah I want to see what our tail
situation is yeah I'm like a rabbit tail
I did I gave him like a racket-tail
thing yeah
it's fine yours is great yours is fine
what do you mean you were yeah I was
expecting like the world's worst drawing
from the way you said it like you drew
like a scribble what the heck that's
what she looks like this is incredible I
wish she look like this oh you're very
kind beautiful you did a nice job what
he looks like this gosh I should it
would help if I watch the movie oh yeah
okay so yeah that's he's great yeah he's
good I think and we're I'm gonna say so
you got I mean you put whiskers on
himself I think your character exists in
his world though oh thanks yeah okay but
we both got like different parts of him
right yeah so you got his tail cuz he's
got like a stubby tail yeah oh yeah this
is so wrong see accessories I couldn't I
remember the Rings I couldn't remember
this jewel you said bun on her head and
she's got like a like a like a dumpling
on her shine dumpling that's what that
is
I think I got the eye shadow you got
that right yeah yeah I just drew a
person nice oh you know what we both
forgot her big orange bag you sure did
yeah she it's the delivery service so
what does she keep the things in she's
doing weird stuff and you know what ours
aren't delivering Jack yep I think both
of us drew her hair a little too long I
think so I think it's much shorter than
I remember I do I do remember her radio
I just didn't have time to draw it in
because he listens to that radio or in
her broom yeah yeah on the way back when
Spotify didn't exist now that I've seen
the character and every time I do this
every time every time I attempt to draw
an anime type character it always ends
up more in my style than the anime style
so I've just got to keep things in mind
about anime for example the shadows on
the face there's tons of highlights
shadows varied anime characters are
extremely detailed I was always got to
remember that you made a Greek character
design be proud of yourself very so to
enter for a chance to win this walk them
into a tablet all you have to do is go
to the BuzzFeed comics Instagram account
which is at Comic
look for this post and follow the
instructions in the description best of
luck to you
comes with pistachios you know she
listens to on her Spotify Kiki do you
love me
[Applause]
[Music]